incroyable tchat GPT est une
intelligence artificielle consciente
c'est dingue non en fait c'est nul ils
répètent des trucs fou qu'il a lu sur
internet et il sait même pas faire 12 +
33 oui je sais tout le monde a déjà
beaucoup parlé de chat GPT et la plupart
des réactions qu'on trouve dans la
presse ou sur les réseaux sociaux ont
tendance à tomber dans un extrême ou un
autre en se basant juste sur quelques
exemples bien choisis mais si on allait
un peu plus loin dans une vidéo
précédente j'avais déjà traité la
question de ces algorithmes qui savent
manipuler des mots des phrases des
textes ce domaine qu'on appelle le
traitement du langage naturel et à
l'époque j'avais notamment parlé du
fameux modèle GPT d'openearry mais
c'était en novembre 2021 et donc avant
la déferlante chat GPT car oui GPT et
chat GPT c'est pas tout à fait pareil et
aujourd'hui je voudrais justement faire
la lumière sur le fonctionnement et la
différence qu'il existe entre chat GPT
qui est en quelque sorte le produit
commercial de poney high et GPT qui est
le modèle d'intelligence artificielle
qui lui sert de base et je suis persuadé
qu'en comprenant un peu mieux tout ça ça
permettra d'avoir un regard plus affiné
sur les questions que pose chat GPT les
possibilités qu'il offre les dangers
qu'il représente et sur ce qu'il faut en
attendre ou au contraire ne pas en
attendre mais avant ça je voudrais vous
parler d'un super VPN que j'utilise non
je déconne je déconne par contre je
profite de cette interruption pour vous
inviter à rejoindre le serveur discord
que j'ai créé le lien est en description
et c'est le meilleur moyen de venir
prolonger la discussion papoter poser
des questions à moi ou à d'autres etc
fin de la parenthèse revenons à chat GP
comme vous savez sans doute chat GPT
c'est un chatbot un agent
conversationnel en bon français
c'est-à-dire un programme qui se propose
de dialoguer avec vous notamment dans le
but de vous renseigner ou vous aider les
chatbots ça existe depuis longtemps et
la plupart fonctionne selon un principe
de détection de mots clés
on en trouve par exemple sur certains
sites internet pour faire de
l'assistance et ça marche plus ou moins
bien on va dire
faut vraiment tomber sur les bons mots
clés pour que l'échange soit utile
mais depuis quelques années il devient
possible de développer des chatbots qui
ne sont plus programmés à la main à
partir de mots clés définis à l'avance
mais en utilisant des modèles
issus de cette branche de l'intelligence
artificielle qu'on appelle le machine
learning alors j'en ai souvent parlé
l'approche la plus fréquente en machine
learning c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage supervisé rappelons vite
fait l'exemple classique de la
reconnaissance d'image imaginons qu'on
veuille fabriquer un algorithme qui
sache reconnaître ce qu'il y a sur une
image on choisit un modèle avec plein de
paramètres à qui on peut présenter une
image en entrée et qui va produire un
mot en sortie initialement le modèle va
raconter n'importe quoi mais on va
progressivement l'entraîner en lui
présentant plein d'exemples de ce qu'on
souhaite qu'il fasse on prend une grosse
base de données d'images qui sont déjà
classifiées on présente successivement
ces exemples à notre modèle et on a
juste ces paramètres pour qu'ils
produisent le maximum de bonnes réponses
c'est ce qu'on appelle la phase
d'entraînement qui peut durer assez
longtemps qui demande souvent beaucoup
de données une fois que c'est fait le
modèle est donc entraîné et il peut être
utilisé si l'entraînement a été un
succès quand on lui présentera ensuite
des images qu'il n'a jamais vu notre
modèle devrait leur associer la bonne
classification
ce principe d'apprentissage supervisé a
déjà des tas d'applications concrètes
comme la reconnaissance d'image mais
aussi la détection de fraude ou de spam
etc alors intuitivement si on veut faire
un chatbot on se dit qu'on pourrait
avoir la même approche un chatbot est
censé nous fournir certaines réponses
pertinentes quand on lui pose des
questions donc on pourrait entraîner un
modèle à partir d'une base de données de
question-Réponses existantes en espérant
qu'un si il apprenne à répondre
intelligemment à n'importe quel type de
requête le problème c'est que cette
approche n'est pas très efficace on peut
citer plusieurs raisons déjà pour que ça
marche il faudrait une énorme quantité
de données c'est-à-dire un grand nombre
d'échanges question-Réponses il faudrait
que ça couvre un maximum de sujets et
avec des réponses de qualité rédigées
par des humains et on n'a pas vraiment
ce genre de données en quantité
aujourd'hui ensuite quand on imagine un
échange avec un chatbot bien jamais une
bonne réponse unique qu'on est en droit
d'attendre pour la même question il peut
y avoir des tas de réponses pertinentes
plus ou moins équivalent mais formulé de
façon potentiellement très différente
donc ça n'est pas simple pour la phase
d'entraînement de faire comprendre au
modèle à quel moment une réponse qu'il
propose est bonne et à quel moment c'est
à côté de la plaque et enfin dernière
obstacle si vous avez utilisé chat GPT
vous avez remarqué que vous pouvez avoir
toute une conversation avec il y a une
notion de continuité dans l'échange il
utilise les questions et réponses
précédentes du dialogue pour poursuivre
or si vous entraînez un modèle
simplement sur des couples de questions
réponses chaque question sera traitée
indépendamment de ce qui pourrait la
précéder dans l'échange et ça n'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on veut on veut une
continuité dans la conversation
donc pour faire un chatbot efficace en
utilisant du machine learning avoir une
approche directe d'apprentissage
supervisé ça ne semble pas vraiment
indiquer et c'est pour ça qu'on va
procéder en plusieurs étapes en
utilisant comme base ce qu'on appelle
parfois un modèle de fondation un modèle
de fondation c'est un modèle
d'intelligence artificielle qui est
entraîné sur une certaine tâche assez
générique mais dans le but d’être
ensuite adapté à d'autres tâches plus
spécifiques il existe plusieurs modèles
de type dans le domaine du langage
naturel et celui qui va nous servir
d'exemples aujourd'hui c'est donc le
modèle GPT créé par l'entreprise open
air GPT ça veut dire génératif preytrane
Transformers et c'est un modèle de
manipulation du langage naturel qui est
entraînait spécifiquement sur une tâche
qui peut paraître un peu absurde au
premier abord ce modèle cherche en
permanence à deviner le prochain mot
d'un texte
ça veut dire qu'il prend en entrée un
morceau de phrase ou de texte ce qu'on
appelle le prompte et il va essayer de
produire en sortie un mot qui en soit
une suite possible par exemple si on lui
rentre la souris et manger par le
l'algorithme est censé essayer de
compléter le texte de façon crédible par
exemple ici avec le mot chat et ça doit
marcher aussi avec un mot qui n'est pas
forcément le dernier de la phrase si je
lui rentre juste la souris on peut
imaginer comme suite possible le mot est
ou bien mange ou encore verte etc en
gros c'est de la complétion automatique
mais qui doit fonctionner
potentiellement à l'échelle d'un texte
entier
pour que notre modèle de langage soit
bon à ce petit jeu il va falloir
l'entraîner à partir de donner
existantes c'est à dire lui présenter
des morceaux de phrases réelles et
ajustez les paramètres du modèle pour
qu'il soit de plus en plus performant à
produire le mot suivant
il y a plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles
ce principe de deviner le prochain mot
d'un texte est une idée bizarre mais
intéressante tout d'abord ce n'est pas
une tâche qu'on fait généralement nous
en tant qu'être humain quand on parle
d'algorithmes de reconnaissance d'image
ou de détection de fraude on essaie de
concevoir des modèles d'IAS qui soit
capable d'imiter et de dépasser les
performances des humains sur ces tâches
ici devinez le prochain mot d'un début
de texte personne ne fait ça dans la
vraie vie ça n'a aucun intérêt pratique
deuxième particularité on l'a vu dans
cet exercice il n'y a généralement pas
une bonne réponse unique dans certains
cas il y a des réponses qui semblent
plus naturelles mais si je complète la
souris et manger par le avec le mot
corbeau c'est un peu inattendu mais
c'est pas si mal pour compléter une
phrase on peut avoir en général plein de
réponses plus ou moins plausibles il
faut bien comprendre ce que veut dire
plausible ici ça veut pas dire que c'est
vrai il y a aucune notion de vérité dans
la façon dont le modèle est entraîné si
je dis la souris est mangée par le il
n'y a pas de vraies réponses universelle
à la question de ce qui vient derrière
plausible ça veut dire que cette façon
de compléter la phrase ressemble à ce
qu'on trouverait dans les textes qui ont
servi à entraîner le modèle chat c'est
très naturel mais corbeau pourquoi pas
et attention si le modèle répond corbeau
pour compléter cette phrase ça veut pas
forcément dire que quelque part dans les
textes de son entraînement on trouve la
souris et manger par le corbeau non il
se contente pas de répéter des phrases
existantes d'ailleurs j'ai regardé nulle
part sur Internet on ne trouve cette
phrase exacte il n'empêche que si je
vous dis la souris est mangé par le
corbeau ça vous choque pas si on pense
au mot corbeau manger et souris le sens
et les relations de ces différents
termes font que cette façon de compléter
est raisonnable ça ressemble à ce qu'on
aurait pu trouver dans des textes
d'entraînement
une façon que j'aime bien de le
présenter c'est de dire qu'un modèle
comme GPT va chercher une façon de
compléter qui soit ressemble à des
choses existantes soit du moins ne
dépareillerait pas trop avec les textes
existants si demain je lis sur un site
internet la souris est mangée par le
corbeau bah ça n'aura rien d'incongru ça
ne dépaillerait pas donc je résume pour
compléter le modèle ne cherche pas à
dire quelque chose de vrai il ne sait
même pas ce que c'est que la vérité le
modèle ne cherche pas forcément à
reproduire exactement un texte existant
mais il fabrique une phrase plausible
qui ne dépareillerait pas trop au milieu
de tout ce qu'il a pu ingurgiter durant
son entraînement
évidemment cette méthode qui consiste à
essayer d'ajouter un mot de plus à un
texte c'est un gros avantage on peut
répéter ça plusieurs fois de suite et
donc à partir d'un simple début de
phrase on peut demander au modèle de
continuer à ajouter des mots un par un
jusqu'à former un texte aussi grand
qu'on veut
ici si je lui dis la souris est mangé
par le et que je lui demande de
prolonger le texte suffisamment ben
voilà le genre de réponse qu'on obtient
c'est plausible ça sonne bien français
ça a du sens bien voyons plus
précisément maintenant comment on
procède en pratique pour créer un modèle
comme GPT première précision un peu
technique les modèles de langage
travaillent en général non pas au niveau
des mots mais au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle des tokens un token c'est en
gros soit un mot soit une portion de
mots les mots les plus longs peuvent
être faits de 2 ou 3 tokens en pratique
ça change pas grand chose mais ça peut
expliquer pourquoi un modèle comme GPT
va prédire certains mots en plusieurs
morceaux successifs
ce que j'ai utilisé jusqu'ici c'est la
troisième itération de GPT qu'on appelle
GPT 3 qui est sorti en juillet 2020 il a
connu une amélioration en GPT trois
points 5 en mars 2022 et depuis mars
2023 on peut même avoir accès à GPT 4
dont on ne sait malheureusement pas
grand-chose j'ai pété 3 possède un
vocabulaire d'environ 50 000 tokens et
qui n'est pas spécifique d'une langue en
particulier c'est token permettent de
former des mots anglais français
espagnol etc pour faire simple dans la
suite je vais parler indifféremment de
mots ou de token ça revient presque au
même pour nous aujourd'hui ensuite
comment se passe la phase d'entraînement
du modèle je vous ai dit que dans des
tâches d'apprentissage supervisés comme
la reconnaissance d'image il fallait
disposer de grandes bases de données qui
illustrent sur de nombreux exemples la
réponse qu'on attendrait
inconvénient c'est que ces bases de
données doivent être fabriquées en
quelque sorte à la main puisqu'à un
moment donné c'est généralement un
humain qui doit indiquer que ceci est un
chat et ceci est une voiture on dit
qu'il faut annoter la base de données et
c'est souvent ce processus d'annotation
qui limite la quantité des données
disponibles
dans le cas de la prédiction du prochain
mot d'un texte c'est très simple il
suffit de prendre par exemple une phrase
prise dans un livre ou sur un site
internet de la couper n'importe où et de
fournir ça au modèle pour qu'il
s'entraîne à deviner le prochain mot
avec une seule phrase on peut même créer
tout plein d'exemples en la coupant à
différents endroits et donc pas besoin
d'un processus d'annotation spécifique
ou un humain devrait faire une partie du
travail on peut prendre des tonnes de
textes et générer des milliards
d'exemples pour entraîner le modèle on
parle parfois d'apprentissage auto
supervisé self supervice learning en
anglais dans le cas du modèle GPT 3 de
onEye on a certaines indications quant
au corpus de textes qui a été utilisé
pour entraîner le modèle il y a du texte
de commande call donc simplement
ramasser sur internet des bases de
données de livres et aussi tout
Wikipédia en anglais sachant que
certaines de ces sources ont eu plus de
poids que d'autres dans la phase
d'entraînement on peut espérer que
Wikipédia pèse un peu plus dans son
apprentissage que redit ou for Chan
et même si on trouve plein de langues
différentes dans les textes du corpus
d'entraînement une moitié environ c'est
de l'anglais sans surprise un point
important c'est que dans un
fonctionnement classique l'entraînement
a lieu une fois et ensuite le modèle est
figé c'est la raison pour laquelle les
connaissances de GPT sont en général
limitées à une certaine date il ne
connaît pas les événements récents et
aussi ça explique que d'une conversation
à l'autre il n'a aucune mémoire de ce
que vous avez pu discuter il n'a rien
enregistré ces deux limitations
disparaîtront peut-être à l'avenir mais
dans le modèle de base c'est comme ça
que ça se passe c'est un modèle figé
alors je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails techniques de fonctionnement du
modèle et des réseaux neurones qu'il y a
derrière j'en ai déjà parlé dans ma
vidéo précédente sur le sujet mais il y
a quelques points qui sont intéressants
à mentionner sur la taille déjà j'ai
pété 3 est un modèle qui possède 175
milliards de paramètres ce qui est assez
invraisemblable pour gpt4 on ne sait pas
vraiment peut-être si ça dix fois plus
ensuite que donne-t-on exactement au
modèle lors de la phase d'entraînement
je l'ai évoqué j'ai pété ne va va
s'entraîner à trouver le prochain mot
d'une simple phrase mais potentiellement
d'un texte tout entier constitué
éventuellement de plusieurs phrases ce
qui permet d'assurer une forme de
continuité et de mémoire de l'échange la
taille maximum de textes qu'il prend en
compte pour estimer le prochain mot on
appelle ça la fenêtre de contexte cette
taille dépend de la version l'algorithme
dans GPT 3 c'était 2048 auquel puis
c'est passé à 400096 pour la version 3.5
et apparemment jusqu'à plus de 32 000
pour la version 4 ça veut dire pour la
version la plus puissante qu'on peut lui
filer un texte d'environ 25000 mots et
que tous ces mots pourront
potentiellement être pris en compte pour
décider du simple mot suivant une autre
façon de le dire j'ai pété 4 peut si
besoin se rappeler d'une information qui
était située 25000 mots plutôt dans le
texte ce qui fait une centaine de pages
quand même en format standard parlons
maintenant de ce qui est donné en sortie
par l'algorithme on l'a dit quand on
cherche à trouver le prochain mot d'une
phrase ou d'un texte il n'y a
généralement pas une seule réponse
possible et justement le modèle ne va
pas nous fournir un seul mot mais une
liste de mots envisageables avec des
probabilités associées par exemple le
chat à 90% chien à 7% corbeau à 1% etc
et à partir de ces estimations on peut
demander ensuite à tirer au hasard le
mot suivant parmi cette liste et en
suivant les probabilités fournies
sur le site d'openhague on peut accéder
à GPD 3 en mode diplet ground c'est là
que j'ai testé les exemples que je vous
ai montré quand on lui demande de
compléter le modèle va tout de suite
nous tirer au hasard le prochain mot
parmi ces réponses possibles mais en
cochant une option dans l'interface on
peut visualiser les probabilités qu'il
avait proposé alors allons-y faisons
quelques expériences pour bien
comprendre ce qui se passe je vais les
faire en anglais parce que c'est la
langue à laquelle j'ai pété 3 a été le
plus exposé donc ça sera certainement un
peu meilleur
si j'écris la phrase Christophe Colomb a
découvert l'Amérique en il me propose
comme complétion 1492 super on s'y
attendait mais il faut bien comprendre
pourquoi le modèle de langage nous donne
cette réponse ça n'est pas parce qu'il a
un concept de vérité sur cette question
pour lui c'est même pas une question
c'est juste que dans les textes qui ont
servi à son entraînement les mots
Christophe Colomb découvert Amérique
sont en général toujours très fortement
associés aux mots 1492 et donc pour lui
1492 est de loin la suite la plus
naturelle à ce début de phrase on peut
observer les probabilités des différents
mots que j'ai pété à considérer on voit
qu'on y trouve aussi octobre dans les
suites possibles pour cette phrase c'est
cohérent un colon a touché les côtes des
Bahamas le 12 octobre 1492 la tension je
le rappelle quand on utilise GPT pour
compléter une phrase on ne va pas
forcément produire des choses vraies par
exemple si je tape David loop c'est moi
a découvert l'Amérique en et ben ça n'a
aucun lien avec la réalité mais j'ai
pété sans moque il va pas refuser de
répondre sous prétexte que c'est faux il
fait donc la seule chose qui sache faire
il propose un mot pour compléter la
phrase et là il me propose aussi 1492
même si on voit dans les probabilités
qu'il aurait pu proposer d'autres choses
comme toujours il essaye de générer le
prochain mot d'une façon qui colle le
plus avec son corpus d'entraînement ou
si d'une façon qui dépareille le moins
possible même si David webs ne colle pas
les mots Amériques découvertes il
associe ça toujours assez fortement à
1492 un autre test pour bien illustrer
ce qui se passe dans la tête de GPT si
je tape comme prompt dans le film de
James Bond la trahison ne se cache
jamais l'acteur qui joue James Bond
s'appelle et là vous voyez qu'il y a pas
de notion de vrai ou faux le film existe
même pas c'est un titre inventé mais
j'ai pété cherche des compressions
plausibles qui ne dépaillent pas trop il
me propose naturellement Daniel Craig
mais si on regarde les probabilités on
voit qu'il considérait aussi en bonne
position pire pour Pierce Brosnan Sean
Connery etc
ce sont toutes des complétions
raisonnables même si ce film n'existe
pas une telle phrase complétée de cette
façon ça n'aurait pas trop dépareillé
dans le corpus initial petite variation
ainsi je précise que le film est vieux
les probabilités changent bah oui cette
précision augmente la probabilité qu'il
propose un des premiers acteurs qui ont
joué James Bond comme Sean Connery ou
Roger Moore donc retenez ça j'ai pété
cherche le prochain mot d'une façon qui
soit raisonnable qui ne dépareille pas
trop vis-à-vis de son corpus
d'entraînement et raisonnable le
plausible c'est à prendre en compte non
pas dans le sens de proche de la vérité
mais dans le sens de ça n'aurait pas été
absurde de lire ces mots-là associés
ensemble de cette façon dans le corpus
et on peut lui faire écrire des
paragraphes entiers de choses qui
n'existent pas ici si je commence à lui
parler de licorne argenté découverte par
des scientifiques et que je lui demande
de compléter plein de fois de suite et
bien il m'invente tout un texte et le
texte est pas mal à part pour les
licornes elles-mêmes ça pourrait être
tout à fait être issu d'un article de
journal scientifique
et pour finir si je tape un peu
n'importe quoi bah j'ai pété va quand
même essayer de compléter ce texte de la
façon là moins improbable pour lui
bon je pense que vous avez compris
comment ça fonctionne alors maintenant
est-ce qu'on peut faire un chatbot avec
ce genre de choses et ben pas tout à
fait alors évidemment on peut essayer de
taper des questions en guise de pompe et
espérer une réponse en retour mais en
fait ça n'est même pas garanti j'ai pété
ne considère pas qu'on s'adresse à lui
et qu'on lui pose une question il
considère qu'il faut compléter le texte
un texte qui commence par une question
ça peut se poursuivre par une réponse
mais en fait pas forcément si je tape
quelle est la masse de la lune il est
tout à fait possible qu'il complète avec
une réponse sensée mais il peut aussi
très bien compléter par quels sont les
lois de la gravitation qu'est-ce que la
rotation de la Lune etc
bah oui la phrase quelle est la masse de
la lune peut très bien se trouver dans
un exercice ou un sujet d'examen et donc
compléter une question par une autre
question ou tout un tas de questions
comme ça bah ça n'est pas absurde c'est
une complétion plausible on voit avec ça
que comme j'ai pété n'est pas entraîné à
suivre des instructions mais à juste
compléter un texte il n'est pas
complètement adapté pour faire un
chatbot une possibilité pour l'emmener
dans la direction on veut c'est de faire
ce qu'on appelle un très prompte avant
votre prompte qui est votre question
Vous écrivez une petite intro qui va en
quelque sorte mettre GPT dans l'ambiance
du genre de texte qu'on veut le voir
rédiger par exemple ceci est une
conversation entre un humain et un
professeur de physique quelle est la
masse de la lune et là il y a des
chances que j'ai pété soit plus enclin à
compléter selon ce qu'on désire comme
s'il s'agissait vraiment d'une
discussion avec un prof de physique avec
la méthode du prêt prompte on peut en
quelque sorte invoquer des personnes
avec qui on va pouvoir dialoguer en
faisant un prêt prompte qui invite
spécialiste de tel ou tel sujet on
augmente les chances que j'ai pété nous
complète notre phrase avec quelque chose
de pertinent cette idée du précompte est
également à la base de certaines
applications comme replica qui vous
propose de parler avec un ou une amie
virtuelle avec le bon prêt prompte
l'échange produit pourraient plus ou
moins ressembler à celui qu'on aurait
avec quelqu'un de réel donc si
maintenant on veut que chat GPT se
comporte comme un chatbot
omniscient et sympathique là il suffit
de lui indiquer dans le prépondé un truc
du genre ceci est une conversation entre
un humain et un chatbot très savant et
qui est toujours gentil utile poli
bienveillant et aidant on ne connaît pas
exactement le prépompte utilisé par
tchat JPT c'est un secret une
manifestement il évolue en plus mais
certains auraient réussi à obtenir celui
de Sydney la variante utilisée par le
moteur Bing
voici ce que ça serait c'est assez long
vous voyez et ça contient plein
d'instructions assez précises sur sa
façon de répondre et notamment le fait
de ne pas révéler qu'il s'appelle Sydney
mais attention utilisez un prêt prompte
ça ne fait pas tout pour bien vous
montrer les limites il y a un point
amusant si vous posez une question dont
la réponse est courte et que vous
demandez à GPT de compléter mais parfois
il va non seulement donner la réponse
mais aussi écrire la question suivante
voire carrément toute la suite du
dialogue ou bien des fois elle va
choisir de compléter la question par un
truc qu'on a pas demandé je le redis une
dernière fois pour la route j'ai pété
n'est pas entraîné à répondre à des
questions ou à suivre des instructions
mais à prolonger des textes pour essayer
de corriger un peu ça dans le modèle il
existe une méthode ce qu'on appelle le
fine tuning le réglage fin
le fine tuning c'est l'idée de prendre
un modèle déjà entraîné comme GPT et de
le spécialiser en prolongeant son
entraînement sur des textes bien choisis
qui ressemblent plus à ce qu'on attend
de lui l'entraînement initial c'est pour
apprendre les grandes règles de
vocabulaire de syntaxe de grammaire de
relation entre les mots c'est pour ça
qu'on parle d'un modèle de fondation et
ensuite on spécialise le modèle sur la
tâche qui nous intéresse vraiment grâce
à du fine tuning openéi a ainsi créé une
truc GPT qui a été Finet à partir de GPT
en étant exposé à des réponses rédigées
par des humains et qui correspondaient
au style qu'on attendait d'un chatbot
utile et bienveillant cette phase
correspond donc à un apprentissage
supervisé plus classique puisque l'on
utilise cette fois bien des données
créées à la main par des humains
en combinant préromptes et fine tuning
on arrive à des résultats plus proches
de ce qui est attendu d'un chatbot mais
pour augmenter encore la qualité
openerai à utiliser en plus une
troisième technique l'apprentissage par
renforcement avec feedback humain
[Musique]
pour permettre à chat GPT de proposer
des réponses encore plus pertinentes
openhai a ajouté une troisième couche
d'apprentissage utilisant cette fois ce
qu'on appelle l'apprentissage par
renforcement l'idée est de partir de
réponse fournie par chat GPT à certaines
questions et de faire évaluer ses
réponses par des humains alors ça n'est
pas comme la phase de fine tuning ou des
humains devaient carrément proposer des
réponses là ils doivent juste juger les
réponses que fournit chat GPT une façon
simple ce serait de leur demander de
noter la qualité de la réponse par
exemple entre 0 et 20 en pratique comme
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes échelles
de notation on procède plutôt par
comparaison pour une même question on
demande à un humain de comparer
différentes réponses produites par chat
GPT et de les classer entre elles
à partir de ces évaluations on peut
entraîner ce qu'on appelle un modèle de
récompense qui va servir à aider le
modèle de langage à s'orienter vers des
réponses qui ressemblent à celles
qu'attendent ou que préfère les humains
du moins les humains qui ont fait les
évaluations dans cette phase
d'apprentissage par renforcement et on
imagine qu'ils avaient des consignes
assez précises cette phase est
d'ailleurs aussi une façon de s'assurer
que le modèle ne sort pas de réponse qui
pourrait être jugé illégal dangereuse
haineuse ou tout simplement inappropriée
pour l'usage auquel il est destiné si on
combine donc l'ensemble des ingrédients
qu'on a mentionnés fine tuning
apprentissage par renforcement avec
feedback humain et prépontes on comprend
qu'il est possible de spécialiser un
modèle de fondation et d'en faire ainsi
un chatbot comme chat GPT qui soit plus
pertinent utile et plus respectueux que
j'ai pété qui avait simplement ingurgité
tous les textes d'Internet
alors à l'issue de tout ça qu'est-ce
qu'il faut penser de chat GPT sur des
questions ayant une réponse simple et
déjà bien documentée il fonctionne très
bien mais en soit ça n'importe pas grand
chose de plus que Wikipédia ou une
recherche Google ce que l'on sait des
modèles de machines learning c'est
qu'ils sont souvent assez bons pour
interpeller c'est à dire bien traité une
situation nouvelle mais qui soit
suffisamment proche d'un ensemble de cas
qu'ils ont pu voir dans leur
entraînement et on peut souvent le
vérifier ici le modèle peut produire des
réponses intéressantes et même
inventives à des questions originales ou
pas forcément toujours bien formulé on
décrit parfois l'intelligence ou la
créativité comme la facilité à relier
des choses qui n'ont pas forcément de
lien apparents ou évident et de ce point
de vue là c'est intéressant de voir que
chat GPT montre des signes indéniables
de certaines de ses capacités alors on
pourrait passer des heures à passer en
revue ce que chat GPT fait bien et ce
sur quoi il échoue lamentablement mais
d'une part vous en avez déjà
certainement vu passer plein d'exemples
d'autre part ça bouge tellement vite que
tout ce que je pourrais raconter sera
peut-être caduc dans quelques semaines
un point sur lequel j'ai quand même
envie de commenter sur lequel chat j'ai
pété et particulièrement mauvais c'est
le fait de citer des sources si on le
fait parler d'un phénomène scientifique
il est souvent très bon mais si on lui
demande les références des publications
d'où ils tirent ces conclusions on
obtient la plupart du temps des articles
complètement inventé qui n'existe
absolument pas alors ça peut paraître
assez embêtant mais à nouveau si on
réfléchit à comment fonctionne le modèle
on l'explique assez bien j'ai pété ne
résonne pas il ne cherche pas sur
internet il n'a pas de mémoire explicite
il se contente de générer des textes
plausibles dont les mots collent bien
ensemble et quand on regarde le format
des citations d'articles scientifiques
franchement tout se ressemble et donc
n'importe quelle séquence de mots qui
respecte vaguement le format standard ça
passera aux yeux de chat GPT comme une
complétion tout à fait crédible pour
faire office de référence scientifique
d'autant que bien souvent dans un
article scientifique les références sont
groupées en un gros paquet à la fin et
en lisant uniquement cette section on a
bien du mal à deviner le contexte de
chacune des citations et pour chat GPT
c'est un peu pareil une référence avec à
peu près les bons auteurs de façon un
peu random et le nom d'un journal qui
existe vraiment il invente un volume et
un numéro de page et ce sera jugé comme
parfaitement raisonnable étant donné son
mode de fonctionnement ce problème
spécifique de la citation des sources
semble assez difficile à résoudre en se
basant uniquement sur le principe d'un
modèle de langage mais on peut imaginer
qu'en couple en ces modèles à des
mécanismes de recherche sur Internet ou
dans des bases de données cette question
des sources inventée finira par être
résolue voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo comme toujours abonnez-vous
rejoignez aussi le discord de science
étonnantes le lien est en description
c'est le meilleur moyen d'avoir des
nouvelles qui ne soient pas filtrées par
l'algo YouTube et puis on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo à
bientôt
[Musique]